thousands of gig workers like Uber
drivers help keep our Valley's economy
alive but one of those drivers says he
was scammed out of nearly a grand from
someone claiming to be Uber support Ryan
Matthew tells us his story in just the
most recent scamming incident involving
the company
Denzel McAlpine drives up to 150 people
around the Las Vegas Strip a week I
drive locals and a tourists I pretty
much drive all around the city locals
travel a lot he's an Uber driver going
on seven years to support his small home
renovation business last week he hit a
milestone 4 000 trips but right now he's
not celebrating that was the amount that
I would have made last week early Friday
morning McAlpine says he accepted a ride
it was canceled soon after then he got a
phone call someone claiming they were
with Uber support and offering a 250
dollar bonus for his Milestone I was
kind of surprised by it but went along
with it on the other line a scammer that
sent him a virtual Uber card to cash out
but for it to work he was told to delete
the debit card on his account when he
pressed the cash out button he was out
nearly nine hundred dollars to know that
I have worked the entire week hard
Bernie and
for it just to be gone and the second
I mean it was it was dreading it's just
the most recent Uber driver scam story
within the past year drivers in Colorado
Texas and Rhode Island all report
similar situations and when McAlpine
reached out to Uber for help this is
what they sent back there was no
evidence to suggest your account was
compromised the same message other scam
drivers say they received this driver
now urging others to look out and hoping
Uber will do the same drivers like me I
wasn't aware until after I got scammed
if there was a little bit more awareness
alert it can be avoided
well listen to this a few hours after 8
news now reached out to Uber for comment
that driver we interviewed said he was
reimbursed every penny he lost now an
Uber spokesperson told us this is an
example of what they call imposter scam
by a third party we'll have more of
their response on our website for you at
8newsnow.com